Bertrand Cantat a appris la mort de la
reine Elizabeth tu l'as pris à quelle
heure toi bah moi je l'ai appris en
grand en même temps que enfin voilà
depuis 16h10 je sais que voilà que ça va
être annoncé d'une minute à l'autre mais
je vous avoue que j'avais encore quand
même eu un petit espoir et j'étais voilà
j'étais vraiment ici déjà on loge
maquillage quand on m'a dit Bertrand le
communiqué viens vraiment tomber et
voilà vos équipes savent que voilà voilà
j'ai réagi parce que forcément parce que
je connais Isabelle
j'ai l'impression parfois que je vis
avec Elisabeth II à tel point je oui
voilà vous le savez je suis fini en
parler à de nombreuses de nombreuses
fois et pour moi c'est une figure qui
représente un peu toutes les granites
l'Angleterre elle est devenue une
granite platine est devenue la
grand-maman ce que vous allez être
débordé